la pandemia provocó 22 millones de
nuevos pobres en américa latina ese es
el balance del informe sobre el panorama
social 2020 de la cepal según la
comisión dependiente de la onu la tasa
de pobreza en la región alcanzó el 33 7%
y la pobreza extrema llegó a 12 5% las
peores cifras en los últimos 12 y 20
años son respectivamente esto quiere
decir que 209 millones de personas se
encuentran en situación de pobreza de
las cuales 78 millones viven en pobreza
extrema y en 2020 estamos estimando que
491 millones de latinoamericanos viven
con ingresos menores de 3 veces la línea
de pobreza o sea 8 de cada 10
latinoamericanos son vulnerables de
acuerdo a la cepal el coronavirus
profundizó los problemas estructurales
de la región más desigual del mundo y la
más afectada por la crisis sanitaria y
pese a las 263 medidas de protección
social de emergencia adoptadas por los
gobiernos en 2020 que sirvieron para
apaciguar un poco el impacto el camino a
recorrer es muy largo
no dejamos de reiterar la urgencia y hoy
más claro que nunca de avanzar hacia un
estado de bienestar con sistemas de
protección social universales integrales
y sostenibles y para ello se requieren
nuevos pactos sociales en 2020 américa
latina' vivió la peor crisis económica
en los últimos 620 años con una
contracción del 7 7% y una tasa de
desocupación del 10 7% para salir de la
crisis sanitaria la apuesta es la
vacunación un proceso que en la región
avanza de manera muy desigual por eso
según la cepal la inmunidad de rebaño no
será alcanzada en 2021